at the Senate impeachment trial house
managers are telling senators they can't
trust President Trump later today
Democrats will wrap up their arguments
for removing the president from office
they focused yesterday on article 1
abuse of power claiming mr. Trump
repeatedly put his self interests above
national security the president called
the case unfair and corrupt and his
lawyers say the Democrats evidence will
work in his favor to vindicate the
president Nancy Cordes is on Capitol
Hill she has more on the strong message
about supporting the president Nancy
what's that about well Anthony a Trump
confidante tells CBS News that
Republican senators have been warned
vote against the president and your head
will be on a pike so far the Republican
senators who are talking seem to be
firmly in his corner even as they
listened to a barrage of evidence
yesterday having to do with article 1
abuse of power today the focus turns to
article 2 obstruction of Congress before
we move to the defense this is
corruption and abuse of power in its
purest form the house impeachment
managers laid out Thursday how they say
the president used his position to
benefit himself the quid pro quo was
discussed in text messages emails
voicemails calls and meetings amongst
top administration officials and top
ukrainian officials the only person who
stood to benefit from the abuse of
office and solicitation of these
investigations was Donald Trump after
more than 16 hours some of their
arguments have grown familiar
president's own words to President
cywinski on the July 25th call you look
at that July 25th call so when President
Trump asked for a favor on a July 25th
call and while some Republicans like
Senators Collins and Murkowski have
appeared to pay close attention others
flicked fidgets spinners it is the same
thing day after day after day rinse it
recycle it and
Senate Democrats cried foul well you're
the ones who voted against new evidence
new testimony new documents so they are
being duplicity and hypocritical they
pointed to a new poll that shows seven
in ten Americans want to hear from
witnesses he covered it up he obstructed
us he's trying to obstruct you and he's
violated the Constitution Democrats also
tried to head off any attacks on the
Biden's the allegations against Vice
President Biden are groundless
but the president's defense team said
the impeachment managers had brought
them up first and they're fair game they
kind of opened the door for that
response so we'll determine as a defense
team the appropriate way to do it the
question now are any of the 100 jurors
still undecided I want to end this thing
sooner rather than later
what should the American people make of
the fact that so many senators appear to
have already made up their minds long
before this trial is even over there are
some but the weight of history the
weight of that trial the requirement
that people are forced to sit at their
desks and listen is very very powerful
president Trump's attorneys are due to
begin their 24 hours of opening
arguments on Saturday but there are some
Republican concerns that those arguments
will get buried if they take place on
the weekend so there's now talk Anthony
of a shortened Saturday session they can
make a few arguments but then begin the
bulk of their case on Monday all right
Nancy Cordes at the Capitol thanks Nancy